périgny tunis est belle et à monsieur
hervé gaymard monsieur le président
d'abord un message d'amitié
évidemment au peuple belge auquel nous
relient tant d'histoires et tant de
projets ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'économie
chacun convient et encore davantage dans
une économie mondialisée que le maintien
des centres de décision économique en
france est capital et en la matière il
n'y a pas de fatalité on a assisté il ya
quelques années au désastre pechiney ce
qui n'a pas empêché sur certains sites
industriels de reconquérir une
gouvernance européenne franco-allemande
pour l' usine de saint-jean-de-maurienne
grâce à l'action de ce gouvernement du
précédent et de votre année ses soeurs
et plus récemment carbone savoie
implanté en savoie et dans le rhône pour
une gouvernance française
mais si on doit être vigilants en
matière industrielle on doit également
l'être
s'agissant de nos opérateurs
touristiques notamment quand ceux ci
sont détenus en majorité par l'état
comme vous le savez la caisse des dépôts
et consignations à une filiale
remarquable très prospère qui s'appelle
la compagnie des alpes sa prospérité est
assise sur les délégations de service
public que lui consentent les communes
support de stations de sports d'hiver
et depuis quelques temps monsieur le
ministre une rumeur s'insinue d'une
dilution du capital au profit
d'investisseurs étrangers et je voudrais
vous dire ici au nom de tous les élus de
la montagne que nous sommes contre cette
dilution du capital au profit
d'investisseurs étrangers
de deux choses l'une soit c'est une
rumeur et c'est très bien
soit ça ne l'est pas et nous vous
demandons de vous exposer parce qu'ils
manquent pas de capitaux régionaux dans
notre pays pour investir dans cette
belle compagnie
je vous remercie la parole dit à
monsieur emmanuel macron ministre de
l'économie de l'industrie et du
numérique
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés
monsieur le ministre je partage votre
point de vue sur la nécessité de
maintenir les centres de décision dans
le pays est en effet le biais que cela
introduit quand ses centres de décision
le quitte donc vous me trouverez de
votre côté sur ce point quand il s'agit
de la compagnie des alpes
c'est en effet le premier opérateur
mondial de gestion des domaines des
domaines skiables avec une grande
expertise reconnue est l'un de nos
principaux opérateurs en matière de
tourisme
il faut se féliciter que sur le plan
stratégique sept opérateurs cherchent à
se développer à aller à l'international
il a un rôle très important en
particulier sur votre territoire
mais il a joué aussi un rôle important
dans l'organisation des jeux olympiques
d'hiver en russie à sotchi
et c'est de l'emploi créé c'est du
chiffre d'affaires c'est aussi de la
compétitivité française à
l'international
la chine aura organisé des jeux
olympiques en 2022 et il est à souhaiter
que la compagnie des alpes
il joue un rôle majeur c'est notre
souhait et c'est bon pour notre économie
et donc elle va chercher des
partenariats elle va chercher à mieux
comprendre les touristes chinois et à se
développer
et c'est comme ça que nous avons des
groupes puissants et donc nous
soutiendrons la compagnie des alpes dans
ce développement à l'international sur
un marché essentiel que la chine ait
éventuellement d'ailleurs dans sa
capacité à attirer des partenaires
chinois
maintenant quand il s'agit du capital le
capital de la compagnie des alpes
c'est un capital aujourd'hui qui est
cotée qui est ouvert qui est public donc
nous n'en avons pas la maîtrise en
totalité mais il est à 40 pour cent
détenue par la caisse des dépôts et
consignations ce que je veux vous dire
clairement c'est que la caisse des
dépôts et consignations ne vendra pas
une action une action au bénéfice de qui
que ce soit voilà pour vous rassurer
ce qui veut dire que dans une entreprise
cotée ça veut dire que la compagnie des
alpes sera toujours contrôlée par la
caisse des dépôts et consignations elle
aura la possibilité d'avoir d'autres
actionnaires peut-être des chinois peut
être d'autres si c'est bon mais elle
sera toujours contrôlée par la caisse
des dépôts et consignations